je comprends que mauvais des moments
difficiles à projet montréal
présentement qu'on cherche
je comprends que l'on va se déchirer la
chemise que vous vous radicaliser mais
tout le monde ici va comprendre qu'on a
pris des décisions à partir d'un
processus bien établie monsieur le
président franchement honnêtement si on
veut jouer à ça aussi on va présumer que
les politiques de l'administration sera
en fonction de ce que ça va bien dans le
parti de la famille ou le couple de
monsieur le maire
là on va se faire des procès d'intention
comme ça ça va être super intéressant
honnêtement c'était irrespectueux
c'était disgracieux et ça n'apportait
surtout rien au débat je veux dire c
noyer le poisson que de prétendre qu'on
pose des questions parce que ça va bien
ou mal dans notre art se pose des
questions parce que c'est notre job
c'est votre job des réponses qui reste
onze ans peut-être que le leader adjoint
n'apprécie pas la véracité ou le
commentaire en aucun cas le commentaire
en aucun cas le commentaire n'est
respectueux ou ne causent matière à
retirer les propos monsieur le président